it's funny because you know I've watched
your show um it's a limited series but
it's this unfolding episodic of um a
very intimate love story at its core
with two human beings um but having
grown up in West Hollywood in the 70s um
everyone I grew up around uh you know
was was gay and I remember the
historical significance of figuring out
what the AIDS disease even was it wasn't
called that at the time the quilt the
blanket the politics of it but when it
goes back into the McCarthy days and the
ramifications that were not only
societal uh for being in a gay
relationship being a gay man or woman um
of which that covers is covered
beautifully too in the show um there's
so much going on I mean you two are at
the center of it and you're both so hot
there's so much hot
like there's so much hot sex in this and
of course I'm just like oh my God I'm
watching I mean don't get me started
with Bridgerton Jonathan
like I'm I'm like I I like you have made
me blush more in the last few
years
than I hand off you're so hot and I
don't understand how you're so
commanding in Alpha and make me feel as
a woman like I'm like whatever you say
and then you are this beautiful gay man
in this intimate relationship making me
like SOB in my bed over you know if we
all are so lucky enough to have love in
this life and I've cried so much in this
show and Matt you're so hot I can't
believe I'm actually sitting next to you
in fact by the way I don't know what's
wrong with me I never meet a straight
man I'm attracted to I only am attracted
to gay man what is wrong with me you
good taste I I I I but it's like I'm
barking up the wrong tree well we love
you we love
you I love you enough for all of us well
I'm proud to say that we actually kissed
the same man who's also gay Andrew rolds
Well I think we should round it out yes
the great Andre Ral and we have to close
the circle the incredible we have to
close the true I
[Applause]
mean this
is this is the only action I get it's
like I well I'll just be in my single
celibate phase and just keep on
fantasizing and come to work where I get
like the best life I've ever
[Music]
lived